the last discrete random variable that
we will discuss is the so called
geometric random variable it shows up in
the context of the following experiment
we have a coin and we toss it infinitely
many times and independently and that
each coin toss we have a fixed
probability of heads which is some given
number P this is a parameter that
specifies the experiment when we say
that the infinitely many tosses are
independent what we mean in a
mathematical and formal sense is that
any finite subset of those tosses are
independent of each other I'm only
making this comment because we
introduced the definition of
Independence of finitely many events but
had never defined the notion of
independence of infinitely many events
the sample space for this experiment is
the set of infinite sequences of heads
and tails
so a typical outcome of this experiment
might look like this it's a sequence of
heads and tails in some arbitrary order
and of course it's an infinite sequence
so it continues forever but I'm only
showing you here the beginning of that
sequence we're interested in the
following random variable X which is the
number of tosses until the first heads
so if our sequence looked like this a
random variable would be taking a value
of 5 a random variable of this kind
appears in many applications and many
real-world contexts in general its model
situations where were waiting for
something to happen
suppose that we keep doing trials at
each time and the trial can result
either in success or failure and we're
counting the number of trials it takes
until a success is observed for the
first time now these trials could be
experiments of some kind could be
processes of some kind or they could be
whether a customer shows up in a store
in a particular second or not so there
are many diverse interpretations
the world trial and of the world's
success
that would allow us to apply this
particular model to a given situation
now let us move to the calculation of
the PMF of this random variable by
definition what we need to calculate is
the probability that a random variable
takes on a particular numerical value
what does it mean for X to be equal to K
what it means is that the first heads
was observed in the case trial which
means that the first K minus 1 trials
were tails and then were followed by
heads in the case trial this is an event
that only concerns the first K trials
and the probability of this event can be
calculated using the fact that different
coin tosses or different trials are
independent it's the probability of
tails in the first coin toss times the
probability of tails in the second coin
toss and so on K minus 1 times so we get
an exponent here of K minus 1 times the
probability of heads in the cave coin
toss so this is the form of the PMF of
this particular random variable and that
formula applies for the possible values
of K which are the positive integers
because the time of the first head can
only be a positive integer and any
positive integer is possible so our
random variable takes values in a
discrete but infinite set the geometric
PMF has a shape of this type here we see
the plot for the case where P equals to
1/3 the probability that the first head
shows up in the first trial is equal to
P that's the probability of heads the
probability that it shows up in the next
trial in that the first head appears in
the second trial this is the probability
that we had heads following a tail so we
have the probability of a tail and then
times the probability of a head
and then each time that we move to a
further entry we multiply by a further
factor of 1 minus B finally one little
technical remark there is a possible and
rather annoying outcome of this
experiment which would be that we
observe a sequence of tails forever and
no hands in that case a random variable
is not well-defined because there is no
first heads to consider you might say
that in this case our random variable
takes the value of infinity but we would
rather not have to deal with random
variables that could be infinite
fortunately it turns out that this
particular event has zero probability of
occurring which I will now try to solve
so this is the event that we always see
tails let us compare it with the event
where we see tails in the first K trials
how do these two events relate if we
have always tails then we will have
tails in the first K trials so this
event implies that event this event is
smaller than that event so the
probability of this event is less than
or equal to the probability of that
second event and the probability of that
second event is 1 minus P to the K now
this is true no matter what K we choose
and by taking K arbitrarily large this
number here becomes arbitrarily small
why does it become arbitrarily small
well we're assuming that P is positive
so 1 minus P is a number less than 1 and
when we multiply a number strictly less
than 1 by itself
over and over we get arbitrarily small
numbers so the probability of
ever seeing a head is less than or equal
to an arbitrarily small positive number
so the only possibility for this is that
it is equal to zero so the probability
of not ever seeing any heads is equal to
zero and this means that we can ignore
this particular outcome and in other
side consequence of this the sum of the
probabilities of the different possible
values of K is going to be equal to one
because we're certain that our random
variable is going to take a finite value
and so when we sum probabilities of all
the possible finite values that sum will
have to be equal to one and indeed you
can use the formula for the geometric
series to verify that indeed the sum of
these numbers here when you add over all
values of K is indeed equal to one